so guys I'd like to talk to you today
about something that's been on my mind
lately and I know it's on a lot of your
guys's mind too because I've seen a lot
of comments like this if I can stay away
from negativity on my channel I like to
unless of course I'm talking about a
horrible movie like movie 43 or anything
like that but this has been building
inside me for many years now and today
something finally happened that made me
just absolutely explode and not be able
to take it anymore and before I tell you
what happened to me today I'd like to
give you an idea of what's been
happening to me over the past few years
so you guys can get an understanding of
how I feel about this now I view movies
and going to the movie theater as a very
special experience movies are my passion
I want to eventually be a film director
I have a lot of respect for the
filmmaking experience for the people
involved with the movies even when the
movies aren't that great I still respect
people for trying because I know that
most of them are trying to do something
they really love and for that reason I
connect with those individuals you more
than likely put a lot of time and effort
into that project they put their life
into it they put their hard passion into
that film and I want to go there and
respect them for that that means I'm
gonna be quiet and I'm not gonna text
during the movie then I'm gonna try to
watch the movie and examine it as
closely as I can so that I can give you
guys an accurate review and I can
actually enjoy the movie experience and
be sucked into it and forget about the
world around me that's the whole joy of
going to a movie theaters you can sit in
a dark room and enjoy a movie if it's
good get sucked into that world and not
worry about all the random little stuff
that's going on around you unfortunately
there's a lot of people out there who
like to go to movies just to pass the
time they really don't care about anyone
else around them they're gonna do
whatever they want while they're in that
theater and I just can't stand that kind
of conduct in a movie theater and for
many years I was very silent about it I
just sat there and took it up the
tailpipe but since I really got serious
and to go into these screenings and
reviewing movies as often as I can for
you guys I've experienced it so many
times that it's gotten to the point
where I always try to do the exact same
thing respectfully kindly ask if the
person could please stop talking so that
I can enjoy the movie I'm not rude about
it I'm not mean I don't demean them and
I'm very quiet about it and I don't
make it a scene out stand up and go can
you please be quiet I always look on and
say can you please stop talking I'm
trying to enjoy the movie sometimes it
actually does work in people like him
I'm sorry I was being a little loud when
that happens it literally is like the
greatest thing ever you like there is
hope for mankind you are one of the
chosen people but sometimes it doesn't
work I'm gonna talk about four
experiences that have happened to me in
this past year that led to what happened
earlier today the first experience was
in the middle of last year where there
is these people behind me throughout the
entire film just talking and talking and
talking and talking completely out loud
without caring reacting to everything
that went on in the screen after like 40
minutes into the movie I just couldn't
take it anymore it was one of those
things where everything that happened
they just say it out loud oh look at
that oh look at that
oh that oh oh look who that is oh I saw
him in that one movie after a while it
was horrible and I couldn't take it
anymore so after like 45 minutes of that
I turned around I was just like guys I
really honestly can't enjoy this movie
can you please stop talking that didn't
work they just kept talking and talking
endlessly throughout the entire rest of
the movie they didn't care so I just sat
there and took it okay that's wonderful
this was at an advanced screening for a
movie - they don't realize that a lot of
people they're actually trying to do
their jobs their legitimate film critics
and being there just going like hey oh
look at that oh oh oh is really freaking
annoying but ok whatever I forgot about
it
so later last year I saw the movie the
house at the end of the street which was
pretty awful there was no press
screening for this film so I had to go
to a normal theater and pay to watch it
which is what I did so I'm sitting there
during the movie and there's this young
girl ok she's this young teenage girl
pregnant
probably at 16 not saying anything there
I'm just saying that's that's what was
there a young pregnant girl part about
16 17 years old she was there with her
friend not paying attention to the movie
at all how do I know that because she
was texting during the entire film and
talking to her friend completely out
loud as if I'm talking to you right now
just like this the movie was so bad
though that I was just like whatever
okay whatever however during the last 20
minutes of the film the couples sitting
directly behind these two teenage girls
the woman leaned over and said okay I
can't take this anymore
you guys got to stop texting and talking
I'm trying to enjoy this
with my husband and everyone in the
theater just kind of looked over and was
like hmm so at that point I saw an
opportunity and I was like I agree can
you guys please stop talking you guys
are gonna look at this as some kind of
racist thing I promise you I'm not
racist in any way I have many friends of
different races black Asian whatever
doesn't matter this is what she said man
all these white people up in here be
tell me to be quiet man I don't like
this all these white people up in here
telling me what to do I'm gonna do
whatever I want so this woman after
sitting through an entire film with her
husband getting extremely annoyed got up
got the manager asked the manager to
tell this woman to please leave now a
manager in a movie theater has to
actually see it herself before she can
ask someone to leave so she stands in
the corner I'm seeing all this by the
way during the last third act of this
movie the managers standing over there
in the corner and the manager sees these
people the manager is just watching and
after like literally a minute the young
girl and her friend to start talking and
blabbing and texting again right in
front of theater manager they do not
care so the manager walks over and goes
you guys are gonna have to leave the
theater because you're just dropping
everyone around you so this teenage girl
stands up looks at the people behind her
takes her soda and pours it all over the
woman and her husband now the husband at
that point breaks he stands up and it's
like he looks at the manager and goes do
your job tell those people to leave pay
for my wives shirt like he's freaking
out and the woman then lunges on the
pregnant woman and a cat fight breaks
out directly in front of me they're
clawing at each other and screaming and
I'm literally just sitting there and
suddenly the movie just got better
no I was actually truly annoyed out of
my mind but there was a fight in front
of me during the end of house at the end
of the street
eventually they escorted these people
out of the theatre the police arrived
there was a person standing at the
theater door literally going like this
with tickets to everyone handing out
free reimbursement passes to every
single person in the theatre I had to
give a statement to the police about
what I saw and I gladly did that because
I was tired of it
that was just that was it you know okay
that's that experience pretty horrible
right yeah pretty stupid why are people
like that it's very annoying you go to a
movie theater to enjoy the film just
shut up but once again try to block that
out of my mind so here's the third
out of four experiences I'm going to
tell you about yesterday I met a preview
advanced screening of the call I can't
talk to you about how I feel about it
because there's still an embargo for the
review yet but I was at the new movie
with Halle Berry yesterday 99.9% full
theater okay there's critics there
there's people from news outlets there
and then people who maybe won their
tickets like off the radio or from some
online contest they're there as well and
you know how sometimes when you sit down
in the theater and then you notice
people are sitting next to you and you
hear how they're acting it's like this
is gonna be annoying isn't it and it
sure enough it was a group of people
behind me probably like five or six
people all knew each other there was
like one young guy behind me probably
early 20s and then a whole bunch of
middle-aged women as well and then one
girl who was probably like three four
years younger than me probably early 20s
as well these people talk completely out
loud to everything that happened I mean
everything oh don't go in that room oh
that's not a good idea
Oh Halle Berry's in this movie oh look
at that cop he's looking hot I swear to
you completely out loud just just like
hey we're in a movie theater filled with
literally probably like four hundred
people but as far as we're concerned
we're at home in our couches I was just
sitting there hoping that in some way
this family would get sucked into the
movie and get into it and stop talking
but this never happened so an hour into
the movie after hearing them talk and
laugh and kick my seat with their feet
and do everything that could possibly be
annoying I finally turned around and
looked at her and went and I'm not
kidding this exactly what I said I'm
trying to enjoy the movie could you
please stop talking in that exact same
tone as kind as I possibly could be
despite the fact that I wanted to just
ah and she looked at me and went I can't
hear a word you're saying and so I was
just kind of staring at her leg and then
what was probably her mother cuz they
looked very similar and she was older
leaned in and went what you saying and I
said I really would appreciate it if you
guys would stop talking I'm trying to
enjoy the movie and she goes oh you're
gonna have to change your seat cuz
everybody up in here be talking I just
turned around in my seat and sat there
in shock like I was just like this is
this is what I do I drove 50 minutes to
get to this preview screening and I
waited in line for two hours
and now I'm sitting here and this is
what I get to experience so at this
screening there are two security guards
down there in the corner I don't know
what their jobs are because I went up to
them and I said I can't take this
anymore this is absurd there's like five
people behind me talking completely as
loud as I'm talking to you right now
about every single thing that happened
on the movie please tell them to be
quiet and this guy and a police officer
uniform goes I don't know if I tell them
to be quiet they'll just keep talking is
there any way that I can find a seat up
in the press box because I can't take
this anymore
and he was like oh yeah man you're at
like every screening I see you all the
time you're cool go ahead go sit up
there it's fine so I had to sit like in
the top-left row all the way in the
corner of the theater okay
now these people that were being
annoying are on the right side of the
theater I am now all the way up at the
top left so they watched me get up go
talk to security guards probably got
nervous about what I was doing now I go
and I sit all the way at the other side
of the movie during this big intense
action scene that's happening and I can
hear the girl go oh he switched seats
that's how loud they were they were
literally shouting it was horrible it
was terrible I can't take audience
members in movie theaters anymore okay
so that was yesterday I'll give you guys
my review of the movie next week I won't
let that encroach upon my thoughts on
the film don't worry so today is when
all hell broke loose I decided to go see
the movie dead man down at 1:50 p.m. at
a Regal Cinemas nearby my house because
there was no screening for this film in
Cleveland so I had to go pay to see it
so that I could review it for you guys
I'm sitting there in this beautiful
theater the seats are leather it was
fantastic
there was me and two other people in the
movie and they were completely silent it
was incredible I felt like I was in
heaven
so the previews are coming to a close
okay I actually watched some of the
previews with no one talking with no one
munching with no one walking in front of
me it was amazing all of a sudden these
two lumberjack men come into the theater
and I'm not kidding they were
Lumberjacks they were wearing denim
overalls combat boots and plaid shirts
they had giant beards
and they were wearing beanie hats they
actually were Lumberjacks like they just
cut down a tree and they're gonna go
watch dead man down with me hey there's
a few more previews left and they sit
down and immediately I know this is
going to be horrible because they're
talking completely out loud now I get it
okay so they're sitting down they just
got in the theater it's only the
previews the actual movie hasn't started
yet okay that's nice so the best
describe my experience I'll let you guys
actually watch what I saw the preview
for James wons new film the conjuring
which by the way looks very cool and
creepy was playing and this is what I
experienced
oh shoot don't go in the closet don't go
don't go in there don't know oh it's a
ghost movie oh I can't take these ghost
movies man these go these ghost movies
no man they do something to me I still
don't know who that girl is
oh oh oh oh don't go in the basement oh
don't oh she's dumb she's going in the
basement I can't believe she's going oh
yep it's a ghost movie it's deaf as a
ghost it's a ghost in the basement man
do not go in the basement it's a ghost
in there they're just sitting like right
there like a couple feet away from me
just right there I couldn't take it
anymore after what happened to me
yesterday night at the call and all
these other experiences I just went sir
can you please not talk during this
movie I please just don't do it and he
went oh okay and of course just kept
talking of course throughout all the
previews just talk talk talk talk talk
talk talk about everything that happened
on the screen I wouldn't have said
anything if maybe they were just talking
to themselves but the fact that they're
just watching everything that happened
and they were reacting to it out loud I
knew they were gonna do to the whole
movie so as the movie previous are
coming to an end and I'm watching the
terrible preview for Tyler Perry's
temptation which just why do I keep
having to see that preview oh I realized
my cell phone's not off so I leaned down
to swipe the little power off thing on
my iPhone and I'm actually holding the
cell phone away from them pointing it
down into my chest so they don't see the
light I'm actually still being courteous
to them and he looks at me and goes no
texting in the theater you're not
supposed to be texting and that was the
last straw
if any of you guys ever watched Seinfeld
I'm going to tell you guys pretty much
exactly what just happened
by showing you a clip from Seinfeld what
are we gonna do SH we just move
necessary by trying to watch the movie
and if I have to tell you again we're
gonna take it outside and I'm gonna show
you what it's like
you understand me such a mouth or I'll
shut him for you and if you think I'm
kidding
just try me try me because I would be
I couldn't take it anymore I got up took
my coat off and screamed at them are you
kidding me I just wanted to come here
and watch a movie in silence and enjoy
the experience and you had to come in
here and ruin it you people make me sick
and I left I got a refund from regal and
I still have not seen dead man down I'm
gonna go see it later tonight after I
calm down but I can't take it anymore
I'm sick of it I am sick of audience
members in movie theaters nowadays not
giving a crap about anyone else around
them being completely insensitive to
everyone else there who paid or who
drove far or waited in line or who
really wanted to see this movie they
don't care about you they just want to
sit there and do whatever they want
whether it's texting their boyfriend or
talking during the film or kicking your
seat they don't care as long as they own
the entire space around them they don't
give a crap about you and for someone
like me who really respects movies and
who actually wants to go to a movie
theater and enjoy myself it is like the
worst and most annoying thing you can do
to me is just sit there and talk on your
cell phone or making noise and I know
you guys feel this way too because you
guys are the special kind of people who
actually go to the movie theater to
enjoy the experience who realized you
know what actually just paid money to
sit down here and enjoy myself and I'd
like to do that and hey movie theater
managers actually do something security
guards and movie theaters actually take
it upon yourself to do your job and be
like shut up
these people are trying to enjoy the
movie they all paid to be here there's
like ten warnings that come up for the
movie starts that says please be quiet
and courteous to others please turn off
your cell phones please be quiet
hey you know we're gonna actually
extract you from the theater if you're
annoying all these warnings come up and
it doesn't ever happen my ultimate goal
in life is to one day be able to open up
a theater chain in which there are
security guards in every single
auditorium and they are commanded to
remove anyone who texts during the film
who talks or who annoys anyone with no
refund and all of you are invited to
that movie theater when I eventually
construct it all of you can come and
enjoy a film in silence so guys I just
wanted to get that off my chest because
I couldn't take it anymore and it's
getting to the point where I don't know
if I'm going to go to some of these
public advanced screenings where they
invite the general public to come for a
free movie because that's all they see
is oh it's a free movie okay I'll do
whatever I want there's no people here
who actually want to enjoy themselves
because it's getting to the point where
I just can't take it anymore I just want
to go to a movie theater and enjoy
myself is that too much to ask
so guys I'd like to know what is your
worst movie theater experience what is
that one experience where you were just
so annoyed that you couldn't take it
anymore and maybe you said something or
maybe you just dealt with it thanks a
lot for watching guys I'll be back later
with an hi review for dead fan down
whenever I finally get to see it today
and as always if you like this you can
click right here and get stuck mine eyes